drame à Marseille un immeuble s'est
effondré en pleine nuit peu avant une
heure du matin une déflagration puis un
incendie et qui complique l'avancée des
secouristes un tas de gravats un nuage
de poussière voici tout ce qu'il reste
de cet immeuble de Marseille
une scène de chaos des pompiers qui
affluent encore une fois nous suspectons
au moment où je vous parle nous nous
devons rester prudents une explosion
dans sa chute il a entraîné deux
bâtiments mitoyens notamment le numéro
15 à gauche
on le voit sur ces photos d'abord
fragilisés par l'explosion
il s'effondra son tour quelques minutes
plus tard nous pensons qu'il y a entre 4
et 10 personnes une dizaine de personnes
sous les décombres l'incendie a toujours
lieu au moment où nous parlons il est
très difficile d'accès puisque les
décombres ont recouvert la
quasi-intégralité de cette incendie elle
Macron qui tweet émotion avec Marseille
ou un immeuble de la rue Tivoli c'était
fondé cette nuit je pense aux personnes
touchées et à leurs proches les
recherches se poursuivent avec
d'importants moyens déployer il faudra
comprendre la cause faire le bilan après
mais je pense que pour l'instant c'est
d'abord l'émotion et ensuite l'intérêt
général et le travail des pompiers pour
essayer de sauver la situation réaction
également de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ancien
député de de Marseille voilà ce qu'il
dit Marseille encore frappé pourquoi le
malheur frappe t-il si souvent à la même
porte on a une crise démocratique dans
le sens où il y a un ressentiment social
qui s'est créé suite à cette réforme de
retraite qui était préexistant
honnêtement et
nécessaire la réforme nécessaire une
réforme des retraites oui mais on
pouvait en faire une autre plus juste
oui nous fondons de grands espoirs dans
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
et nous nous battons depuis des semaines
pour avoir une construction de la
démonstration juridique qui soit la plus
solide possible aujourd'hui plus
personne ne domine rien et le en même
temps à tout cassé et donc on est dans
une situation très particulière où il
n'y a plus de leader et où la classe
politique me semble-t-il n'a plus la
culture du politique vous êtes en train
de nous dire que Emmanuel Macron est pas
à la hauteur de la fonction ça vous a
pas échappé tous les moyens sont bons
pour que cette réforme injuste inhumaine
soit retirée et quel que soit l'issue
d'ailleurs du résultat vendredi prochain
nous ne lâcherons rien 49.3 on peut
considérer en effet que il n'y a pas
d'onction démocratique mais ce que vient
donner le Conseil const itutionnel ça
n'est pas une onction démocratique il
vient répondre à une question est-ce que
c'est constitutionnel ou est-ce que ça
ne l'est pas nous nous prétendons qu'il
y a de grands motifs d'un
constitutionnalité on prône
le en même temps en même temps à droite
en même temps à gauche on est arrivé à
un résultat fantastique on a cassé la
gauche et cassé la droite et quand on
casse à gauche et qu'on casse à droite
où sont les oppositions aux extrêmes
droites extrêmes gauche l'obstination
est mauvaise conseillère et on a un
président qui est un forcené alors on
continuera par d'autres moyens donc que
le Président de la République
assez forts
n'écoutez plus que vous-même j'ai pas
tellement d'autres adjectifs que
celui-là est-ce que lui vous avez
l'impression qu'il y a un truc d'orgueil
avec lui pour qu'il vous pointe comme ça
faut lui demander est-ce que vous l'avez
reçu qui s'appelait Laurent qui l'a
piqué son goûter j'en sais rien mais
mais au bout
n'avez pas l'impression qu'il vous en a
fait un goût
le top départ est lancé
pape François prononcé ce midi sa
bénédiction
Urby et orbi à la ville et au monde
après avoir célébré la messe devant 100
000 personnes réunies place Saint-Pierre
le Souverain Pontife préoccupé notamment
par la situation Proche-Orient Périgord
Bretagne dans toute la France les
chasses aux eaux sont lancés je
manifeste ma vie d'inquiétude en raison
des attaques de ces derniers jours
qui menace le climat souhaité de
confiance et de respect réciproque
nécessaire pour reprendre le dialogue
entre israélien et palestinien afin que
la paix règne dans la ville sainte et
dans toute la région